better yet deal what the [ __ ] would you
do with your skill set if you were in a
comic what in the world would you do you
got a bevy of skills though he really
does yeah urban planner I graduated
college or urban planner didn't graduate
college you were homeschooled
he built exactly st. Louis that was his
design that entire said dude do you want
to get hired as the bird at Red Robin
with that couldn't be around kids just
might say I would have got a sex change
I'm gonna lesbian about some hot chick
to [ __ ] take care of me yeah that's
actually very legit if you are no [ __ ]
if you're a young guy and you were like
things aren't going for you so well
somewhere get 10 grand get a crock get a
real [ __ ] and just get tits
is that all the cost to get don't get it
tits are so easy that's what's and in a
man's chest and it feels like tits oh
yeah - you guys look in this rolling you
get tits you suck the dude off for a
year so get paid and then get married
right and then you just get rid of the
tit that's such a long plan come off for
a couple years you cut off you have a
big deal get rid of it what do you so
much more so your stupid [ __ ] plan
dude it sounds like inception right off
your dick for like wrap travel into the
past
leave your dick to a 3d printer have it
printed out take a space
I'm telling you little twinks that are
back at home you're not getting a girl
or whatever if you want to change your
life save up 10 grand
get a little Siraj installed all eights
bro but here's what I'm saying get 10
grand it costs way more than 10 granting
a gender reassignment no it doesn't
weigh more Chen look that I've been
watching alway nervously mexica not do
it's way more in Mexico to go to Mexico
that's definitely where you don't want
to go to get your dick cut off no you
can get a dick for a nose instead and
please sleep you idiot they don't just
say you don't when you wake up in a
bathtub with your like organs missing
yeah your dick what did they take the
other ones do it averages they needle
that's for those jobs
what is a hundred grand
Trixie's Randy seeds okay you're some
jazz on TLC I see alone
a typical genital plasti alone so 18,000
is what you're looking it that's for
nose job you [ __ ] genital plaster you
think what is on your nose huh Brett
says rhinoplasty is this is rhino
that's 4314 typical genital plasti cost
18 grand
yeah the top last he's not always
exchanged ginetto plastic by the way dad
always an upcharge
that's like that's like when you go to
the nuts is extra how much for the nuts
has got anymore
well that's just taking like that's like
making more ants and it costs more on
what you leave with it in like a it's
like when you get an urn when someone
dies I do you want them in a nice urn
and a glass one or a box I'm sure when
you're doing things it's way more
expensive eighteen to start you guys are
not eighteen denied this I'll say this I
would cost 17 grand mailed a female yeah
great we just saved a thousand dollars
is better this conversation another 10
minutes a disgust won't be a 10-gram
where I want to be at what I'm telling
you freaking animals is this do how much
our tits no chin to my point tits are
almost free bro you could [ __ ] get at
it anywhere does what I'm they give them
away now yeah there's a guy down in
Venice Boardwalk that does it if you
watch his YouTube video you guys a fan
of fake titties bitchin dude dude you
know why when your girl hasn't that's
why you love them no hold on I yes I've
always loved them no first of all I
think I would do one on one off because
yeah sometimes you won't wanted someone
you don't like this just the left side
I'm sorry you can rotate them to the
back with real ones like real ones you
wrote a lazy his wife seems lazy susan
but i want to say this though is that so
listen to your little fellows if you
need you're a young guy maybe your bones
to having developed that strong or
something and you need to get out you
you know things aren't going well at
home for 20 grand or now it's 17 grand
you can get a gender reassignment
you can get a vagina you come out here
dude sell that young ass to some [ __ ]
rich boys out here you could be making
10k
a sore vagina you mean sell that young
vajayjay not ass is still there you got
the end no but why wouldn't you sell the
vagina I wouldn't sell my ass Renata
some double bro we can you just said you
would humble blow realize you're one
here you're a terrible businessman dude
you get the sex change then you sell
your use that you go the whole time and
you would chop off your [ __ ] and then
you'd suck a bunch of guys off you said
you're gonna blow first of all you're
not gonna give up your ass or your new
[ __ ] you decide about gay sex in here
have a sex change then give up your
[ __ ] man I'm saving a vagina for
[ __ ] married not everybody's
wondering given their [ __ ] away to
somebody it would be such a [ __ ] as a
transgender Theo you just know I would
muck and sweet the library I would be
taking care of myself I would be
different well what job would you have
where would you work huh where would you
hard work for the city dude
yeah tollbooth a lot of TJ's in disease
I could see you doing uh I could see you
doing the the meter maid I could see you
doing that rippin tickets oh yeah a lot
of teachers oh yeah dude I thought it
was trans gingers when I first heard I
nobody did the redhead that's like I saw
them I was like they've been through
enough
we all are allowed to get free news
before you get this on sex change you
educate yourself on the government this
favorite book is the movie of mice and
men okay all of you guys get a job in
teaching the teachers are on strike both
of you guys could go field could be
teaching your [ __ ] seven-year-old
right now about transgender sit down
guys
well I doesn't have to be that boys why
would you say why don't you just talk
regular I'm gonna do my same my natural
voice if I'm trans dad that's a turn-off
if you did yeah let me hear your
transgender voice alright hey guys I'm
Robin and I me or guide for today so I'm
gonna dim the lights a little bit
because my [ __ ] blood starts to boil
because I've had so many bad pills and
in my body so I'm gonna go take a nap
you guys teach yourselves yeah that's a
guide well then what were you where were
you showing but what was the guide for
well I was this teacher I'm a study I
must teach students I'm a study hall let
me hear your voice if you got
transgender surgery see I would go
opposite I get a deep voice kind of
everybody its Gina here you'd be a Gina
it's Gina here and I teach geology see I
go opposite because I feel like it's
it's [ __ ] up and just to go opposite
and you didn't do that of course he's
gonna go with the female voice I feel
like that's too on the nose in his head
Gina and I think we all did you think of
any
there's no his brain is like geology
geology yeah just the most obvious a
female voice hey guys this is Robin no
I'm teacher hey guys this is Robin oh
I'm Dave [ __ ] what would you do Santino
I'd stick with the same voice I wouldn't
tell hold it audio did it but it would
them with the beer I go hey guys it's me
and you play for the Bears oh yeah oh
yeah Jimmy J color if you got a sex
change everybody would have understood
his stats I guess right now yeah yeah
yeah yeah watch your tongue oh what's
gonna happen what are you gonna do use
some of that boxing you've been doing
[ __ ] dismiss it